haha the Joe Rogan experience if
anything it's a dress rehearsal for
death I mean you're gonna that's up the
thing is is like that blink if you're an
atheist which you know I I get that and
I think there must be some like deep do
you know any atheists that have done
like a real blow out psychedelic session
now I know a couple and those those are
the most puzzling to me because the guy
people have done like real blow out
mushroom sessions or blow out DMT
sessions I always think that they would
leave the door open to the impossible
because it is impossible and you
experienced it it's not like even if
you're imagining it I couldn't imagine
that so how am i imagining that how am i
imagining something in such incredible
vivid color and and detail and and
knowledge and love and all these
different things the experience in that
state that state is otherworldly the
fact that that is accessible at all I
don't care if it's through a molecule or
through a yoga session I don't care how
it's accessible if the fact that that's
accessible at all leaves open to me the
I don't know because I didn't know that
that was a thing
so once I've experienced that I'm like
oh well all this flat plane of existence
that we take for granted that we think
this is this is everything around us
this is the whole environment you have
to worry out for this might be just one
[ __ ] stage on the radio dial of
experience right and of dimensions that
are interacting with us we just don't
have the senses to to tune into them and
when you can for me at least it leaves
open the door for who the [ __ ] knows who
knows man I just the fact that that's a
thing there's that okay so this is a
trip this this is very trippy so I got
this book called the Tibetan yoga of
dream and sleep well I feel like it's
[ __ ] cool but basically it's like
it's form of Tibetan Buddhism that
invites you to explore the difference
between when you think you're awake and
when you're dreaming and so basically
the idea is there isn't much of a
difference there like right now you're
dreaming
this thing you call your human
incarnation it's like it is a dream and
you know like when people are dying they
get all delirious and [ __ ] they slide
through time you know like I don't know
if you ever been around a dying person
but they they like suddenly they're back
in Vietnam they're in the 50s
they're in the 30s where however
whatever their lifetime which means that
when you're dying you're gonna like spin
through time - meaning that this could
be you dying right now spinning back
with you time but like in a dream so
that when you you know this is the main
thing about it is that when we die
according to this we we sort of spend
like 39 days I think it is in a place
called the Bardo which is essentially
like what it's like to have no body but
still have this like is basically like
your karma your identity sort of
propelling you through and that that
that's how you like you get your next
incarnation so essentially like that's
the what we're dealing with here is so
bizarre and surreal that it easily could
just be a dream state that one of these
vast a eyes that already exists is
having we're just processors we're just
being run it's like running a simulation
of a pandemic or maybe this is a way
that like an AI gets polished like maybe
we're an AI that's being like polished
and taught through this process of
having a limited incarnation you got to
have that so that there's a reason for
us to actually invest ourselves and
stuff like if we were gods if we live
for a million years
eventually we wouldn't have such a
passionate relationship I think with the
world anyone who's gonna it so you need
that to train the thing up so it takes
it seriously you have to put the setting
on mortal then you know then maybe you
just run a series of tests on the thing
you know you start run what is this what
have we made what does it do in a
pandemic and by it I mean the sum total
of all humans which is right now
disconnected it's like a malfunctioning
brain the synapse you know what I mean
we're not connecting but if
or being like sort of I don't know how
you put it groomed evolved intentionally
then every single moment in an
individual's life and in a planet the
planets the life of history could be
looked at as a training or an upgrade
this could be an operating system
upgrade this could be what an operating
system upgrade looks like in the
bio-computer that we exist in it looks
like a [ __ ] pandemic and that's
what's happening right now is we're
being like upgraded for some reason even
though it's terrifying and obviously
horrific you know we're being upgraded
and when you anyway the whole point is
man this thing that we're in right now
whether or not there's a god we just I
think an atheist gets to lean into the
idea that when they close their eyes and
breathe their last breath it stops and I
just think that's a big gamble man
that's and I don't mean because you go
to hell I mean how nice would that be
yeah if it just stopped
when more than likely it's you know the
at least in this Tibetan yoga of
dreaming and sleep more than likely what
happens is way before you actually die
when you get really sick you already
start waking up into your next life you
just wait you just like go through a
weird dream like stay called the Bardo
or you freaked the [ __ ] out and then
you're suddenly alive and another being
completely oblivious to whatever your
past incarnations were and not to or in
right now so you know I don't know this
is a great time for people to start you
know looking at that in one in preparing
for that
[Applause]